your story is well i'll let you tell it
but i mean you started out as a
bricklayer in east london uh and you
kind of lied your way into a stock
market job ended up in hong kong got
fired very quickly did ban like tell the
story because i mean you do it so much
better than i do i don't think the word
lie i think i was just creative with the
truth okay you got some truth yeah
i think my my name my home address and
possibly my birthday i wouldn't even
guarantee that
were accurate on the resume um but yeah
i was a i was a bricklayer from east
london and i remember one day and if
anyone's watching this you know that
they already can see that i'm a 250
pound of biker simple as i always have
been always will be um
and i used to go down to the local pub
with all the other bikers and i remember
being in that room and realizing that
everyone in that room
was a broke ass biker
and i realized that you're always a
combination of the room that you are in
so
that's me i'm a broke ass bite as long
as i stay in this room that is what i am
so i didn't want to be that person i
wanted to be something better i want and
this was in the 80s where we had wall
street the movie and all these and there
was all this opulence being talked about
and rolex and of course we didn't have
instagram to show us how you know
inadequate our life was back then but
you know we were watching james bond and
we were watching wall street and all of
these movies and all these far away
destinations that i knew i would never
visit and never naturally be around
as long as i stayed in that room so i
tried to change the room i was in and it
led me on a journey of discomfort um
discouragement uh being fired and a
friend of mine once uh that got a job in
a banking organization
he actually said to me
that doing a big hiring platform for
hong kong
um come on in you know we'll we'll talk
to you you know they'll they'll train
you up and then you could possibly get a
apprentice stock broken position
in hong kong in the new office so i
turned up
there were about 200 people sitting in
this room
and they literally just grabbed like 60
of us
and gave us the job to go to and in my
resume
i wanted it to be funny because i had
nothing to be in there i even wrote in
there a paragraph about how i was
related to the queen of england
i wanted you to read this resume
and realize it was bollocks
but just kind of smile and go well
the guy the guy made me laugh i'll give
him a shot that's what i was going for
so it was greater fiction than harry
potter
they didn't read it they literally
didn't read it they literally looked
around obviously there had been some
kind of connection with me and him so
they just let me through the net
60 of us went over to hong kong 60 of us
did orientation in the shangri-la on the
monday and on the tuesday i was fired so
they they realized i had no but now i'm
in hong kong what did they fire where
are you for like what did they pick up
on when they said right this guy's not a
good fit oh yeah you know where do you
the funny thing was was
we were in the shangri-la or shangri-la
hotel for orientation on hong kong
island and then on the tuesday we were
taken into uh um victoria harbour for
where their office was and as i came
into the reception you had to get your
badges that was the first time we'd been
in the office because the day before we
were in the conference room of the hotel
so you went in to get your credentials
they didn't give me my credentials
they literally went um could you speak
to so and so they're waiting for you in
the boardroom so again 250 pound a biker
i'm in there with a
99 suit on and i walk into this room and
there's two guys that were smaller than
me if they were combined
and they're both looking at me
and they know they're gonna fire me
because they've obviously done some
checking they've looked at the resume
they looked at the
tests that i was doing the day before
and realized i knew nothing
and they were like um
we were just completing our file mr sims
um where was your series seven license
we can't seem to find it here and i went
i don't have one of them
and in england you can get one that was
an 11 that was similar to the american
version of this this series seven and
they went oh yeah i forgot you're from
england
you probably got the 11.
now i don't have that either
and of course they're both looking at me
they both know that they're firing me
but they're both looking at each other
going you tell him no you tell him no
you and again and in that moment
i just smiled because you knew it was
happening you knew it was coming and
everyone just started laughing and the
guy looked at me in the middle laugh and
he went
you know you're fired don't you and i
went yeah i know and they went what were
you thinking i said i just wanted to try
something i never want to be the guy
that doesn't try and he said well here's
a little bit of good news because we got
you over here
we have to even though we fired you
today
give you your three month salary
and you get the apartment for three
months okay
so i'm like yeah now the apartment
that's what got you in the nightclub
business and i want you guys to stick
around because i mean the story's going
to get real good because he's the kind
of guy that i mean he runs parties for
guys like elton john if you want to go
down and see the titanic it's been
arranged you want to get on the stage
with your favorite rock band you can
make it happen so
this is this is most definitely a
playing to win story that definitely
deserves a place on this uh playlist so
you're in hong kong and then you kind of
pivot to something else because you got
to sort your life out from there you got
to sort your life out i tried loads of
things failed so i became very educated
on what i couldn't do um ended up being
in the nightclub one night and literally
just thought like all entrepreneurs
this is it this is it this is my
basement uh i left a noble profession
of being a masonry being a bricklayer a
proud industry and now i'm just in the
middle of a nightclub in wanchai trying
to get drunk and quite simply that night
honestly i wanted a fight uh i was very
depressed i was very upset with my life
my wife was still in england and i was
lying to her that everything was going
well because of course i was still
getting paid this is still the same
woman that you're with today yeah we met
we were 16 and 17. so you know we
celebrate 37 years this year i think um
but um
literally there was a bit of trouble
inside the club and the the lady asked
me would i sort it out
and i thought why are you asking me i
got nothing to do with this pub and she
turned around and she said well you're
big and ugly you know if you sort it out
i'll pay for your drinks
and she had me at that so i went all
right so i saw it i became the doorman
now
here's where a pivotal twist happens
entrepreneurs and we're based on the old
dr sean stevenson statement we look at
things under two ways did it happen for
us or did it happen to us
now i'm on the front of a nightclub
where my job description is to punch
people
and i had the chance like my other me
heads to just avoid as many fights as i
could and then go home with the tips and
takings from the night
or could i make this better for me i
suddenly realized i had an incredible
pedestal
to human psychology to watch people
interact with each other you know you've
seen people and you know me and you have
been in a lot of same circles you know
people that are really wealthy
the way that they talk handle themselves
walk around interact and then you've got
those people that are pretending
you know the guy that's bought a new
watch
and he's got his left sleeve rolled up
just so you can notice his new watch the
rich guy couldn't give a [ __ ] and i
remember um giuseppe risi the guy that
owns the largest ferrari dealership in
texas said to me once the guy that turns
up to a ferrari dealership in a suit on
a saturday can't afford one the guy that
turns up in shorts and sandals on a
tuesday he's on his third
so i suddenly got to see
how people interacted and then i started
trying to have conversations with them
and the manager would see me not only
protecting the front door but now
walking around the club only to the
booths going hey guys you're having a
good night you know what what are you up
to
and interacting with him
and almost doing his job you know when
you're in a restaurant now and a manager
asks you having a good night i was doing
that because i wanted to have the
conversation
and then i would get people saying to me
oh are you going to that party or do you
know about that nightclub or do you know
about that concert
and i realized very early on
if i could be the solution to your
problem
you didn't care what i look like
so if i could get you into this club if
i could get you into the release of a
new cartier line if i could get you into
the unveiling of a new mercedes or into
an award show
i had your attention for one i'm gonna
charge you because if they don't pay
they don't pay attention
but my whole goal was a trojan horse i
launched the world's largest concierge
firm because i wanted to have a
conversation with you the day after and
ask you why you were successful
and i wasn't
i wanted to get educated and that's what
happened
and then you turned into this uh
connector of people and that's where the
bluefish brand came from i think it was
kind of like a secret word to get into
the clubs
yeah i used to have these little stupid
words i used to like to have people
smiling as they walked into an event so
i would always say like okay
tonight's event it's at the dock at
eight o'clock when you see the doorman
your password is you've got to name one
of the teletubbies
you know or you've got to you've got to
name um
a big bird's mate from sesame street
and so people would like to stuff i
guess wasn't it yeah so people would
literally walk up to the dorm and go
snuffleupagus and they go oh here you go
now here's the thing look at you rich
the amount of people that walk into the
club smiling and giggling because
they've just said a silly word yeah
i had never any trouble in my party and
of course more you imagine it's almost
like you're pumping a drug into a party
everyone that walks through the door now
someone actually said this to me one day
about that was my secret sauce and as
entrepreneurs we usually don't know what
we're good at until we're you know it's
brought to our attention
but someone said to me they said we
always love the front door the inside
front door of your clubs because the
enthusiasm that bleeds through it is is
contagious and i didn't know what they
want about
if you ever go to a club or a bar and
the door opens everyone looks at the
door
but no one's smiling that kind of scope
who's coming in is it a hot girl is it a
threatening guy you know who is it you
know this is this is almost like um
aggressiveness to who's coming through
the door
but in my events everyone was always
coming through the door smiling
and so they always loved it i ended up
throwing these events
i ended up working for oh my god
anything you think about planet from the
macau fashion week milan palace uh new
york uh when it was seventh on six and
it was bryant park in the in the tents
the grammys the new um the uh elton
john's oscar party uh the um palm beach
art fair the florida boat show mtv
awards super bowl i've worked for the
biggest largest events in the planet
and i've ended up working on their
marketing and branding as well and
that's why i've got sims media now but i
worked on all of those
only to be able to get into the rooms i
needed to be because back then
we didn't have podcasts you know back
then we didn't have instagram back then
we didn't have you know youtube channels
we didn't have any of the environments
for us to be able to receive
this information from so i had to create
a reason to be able to have a
conversation with
elton john richard branson jean-paul de
jouria you know elon musk you know name
them i created experiences to be able to
have that conversation
and then i used the information i got to
make sure i was successful from it hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you